however the situation overall is now
a very positive one um and so that means
we are in a position
to relax more restrictions and to
restore
much more normality to our everyday
lives which i know is something
that everybody is desperate to see so
that
improved position overall is why i am
able to confirm today that from
next monday at the 17th of may all parts
of mainland scotland with as i said the
highly probable exception of murray
will move from the current level three
down to level
two but before i set out what that means
let me address the exceptions to that
uh firstly some further detail and
context on that situation
in murray at the moment across scotland
as a whole we're seeing 23 new cases
uh a week for every 100 000 people in
the population so
at levels are relatively low and much
lower than they've been for a long time
in scotland as a whole but in murray
rates are more than four times higher
than that just now and stand
at around 94 new cases per hundred
thousand people
as i said earlier there is in the
opinion of public health experts
widespread community transmission
happening
in murray just now and so it's against
that backdrop
that unless the situation was to
materially improve
over the next few days it would simply
not be safe or sensible to ease
restrictions there
from monday and that's why i have to
flag up today that it is highly probable
that muddy will stay at level three
for a further period it's also important
that we take precautions to reduce the
risk
of the transmission of covid that is
happening within murray
spreading from there to other parts of
scotland as restrictions start to ease
more significantly elsewhere
so if murray does stay in level 3 which
as i said earlier will be finally
decided at the end of the week
we will also reimpose travel
restrictions
again for a hopefully short period and
this will mean that travel in
and out of murray will be limited to
permitted purposes only
if the decision is to keep money at
level three and right now i do consider
that to be very likely i can confirm
that we will provide additional
financial assistance to businesses
that will be affected by that and also
given how
deeply unwelcome i know this will be for
people living in
the murray area i can also confirm that
we will be doing
everything possible to ensure that any
extension of level three
is for as short a period as possible
we're already working closely with both
murray council and grampian health board
to reduce case numbers as quickly as
possible for example
a mobile testing unit has been moved to
elgin and people have been strongly
encouraged to take up lateral flotes
and i would appeal to everyone living in
the murray region to follow all of the
public health advice
so that we can get the situation back
under control just as quickly as
possible
and then allow money to get back onto a
positive track
as soon as it is safe and possible to do
so
now looking to the other exception
before i come on to the general picture
across scotland
for our island communities the situation
is different and
very much more positive case numbers
have consistently been at low levels
very low levels indeed
for some time now many islands also now
have
very good vaccination coverage and
lateral flow tests are available for all
people traveling to the islands
from other parts of scotland so for
those reasons we've decided that it is
possible
and proportionate to now ease
restrictions
on the islands more quickly and that
will be for
island sorry communities in the western
iowa shetland and orkney
for all islands in highland except sky
given the fixed link
to sky and for the inner hebrides
islands in argyll including
isla jura and mull all of these areas
will move directly to level one
from monday rather than to level two
and the full details of what that means
are available on the scottish government
website but for example it means fewer
restrictions
on indoor hospitality now everywhere
else in scotland we'll move to level two
from monday so i now want to spend just
a little bit of time setting out what
that change means in practice it means
firstly that we will be able to meet
outdoors in groups of
eight uh from up to eight households
rather than in groups of six from six
whole
households as is the case now and
even more significantly we will be able
from monday to meet in each other's
homes and that includes for overnight
stays
now it was initially intended that at
level two
up to four people from no more than two
households could meet indoors
however we consider that it is possible
now to go slightly further than that
so from monday up to six people from
three households
will be able to meet indoors in each
other's houses
now this is still a cautious change but
it is
also a hugely important one it is almost
eight months now since most of us have
been able to meet
in each other's homes and it has been
even longer than that for those of us
living in glasgow and
lancashire i know how much everyone has
been
looking forward to being able to do this
again it is one of the
simple pleasures of life that i suspect
and i hope actually that none of us
will ever take quite so much for granted
again
now this is an important change in and
of itself but i am
also pleased to say that in one respect
we consider that it is possible at this
stage to go
further than previously anticipated
so from monday if you are meeting
friends and family
within the permitted limits of course
either indoors in a private
dwelling a house or in your garden our
guidance will say that it is no longer
necessary to maintain
physical distance which means uh and
actually
but emotional saying this that from
monday as long as you stay within
permitted limits
you can hug your loved ones again i know
how desperate we all
are for this so i don't intend to
immediately pour cold water on it don't
worry but there are two further points i
really
need to make firstly it remains vital to
be cautious and to ease
these restrictions carefully so for the
next three weeks at least
the easing of the guidance and physical
distancing will apply
to permitted gatherings in our own homes
and gardens only
however over that period we will also be
conducting a wider review of the need
for physical distancing
in public indoor places and we'll set
out the conclusions of that
at the next review point and secondly
this is
perhaps the more difficult point please
use careful judgment at close physical
contact
does still carry risk i've got to be
very clear with you about that
so if you have loved ones who are
vulnerable for any reason
please still be careful and limit the
overall number of people that you're
choosing to have
close physical contact with it is at
this point just worth making the point
that as we progress
i hope further into the next phases of
the pandemic
and easing restrictions as we try to get
back to normal
prescriptive rules and regulations will
increasingly give way
to greater personal judgment now that
can and will be difficult we've all been
used to following very rigid rules in
the past year
but getting away from that back to the
exercising of personal judgment is an
essential part of that gradual return
to normality so please continue to be
careful and cautious as we take these
next steps forward